hello my friend
before we start this amazing episode i
want to invite you to the personal
patreon page of this podcast
if you love what's being done here
and want to keep the podcast and the
meditations free to the public
then you can come on over to our brand
new community on patreon
and donate 11 and 11 cents a month and
all proceeds will go towards keeping
this free keeping this going
plus we'll be building a community
together and i'll give you
bonus material
you can explore this option in the
description
of this podcast
or just go to patreon.com
dr reese
let's begin
welcome to inner peace with dr reese
a program that can help you become
liberated in the modern world
now
here's your host
dr kevin w reese
so why do we need
90 essential
nutrients welcome to episode number 113.
today i'm sitting down with one of the
fathers of epigenetics
dr joel wallach
he was a world renowned
veterinarian who performed thousands
upon thousands of autopsies
in doing that
he discovered some things about
nutrition
later he became a naturopathic physician
and brought that knowledge over to help
human beings
we're going to talk about diseases
and how to get rid of them through
nutrition we're going to talk about some
of the groundbreaking work that dr
wallach has done in his career
so sit down
relax
[Music]
and take in this beautiful and important
recording
let's begin
doc wallach welcome to the podcast well
thank you so much
so how did you discover the importance
of the 90 essential nutrients
well it all began when i was four years
old
one of those stories
between ages 4 and 9
my parents took me to 20 different
doctors
i was very violent
couldn't remember my name all that kind
of stuff
and
went to 20 different doctors they didn't
even have a name for what i had
and
the 20th doctor a little grandmotherly
like person 80 years old
from st louis uh
dr mary jane skeffington was her name
and
she says well
he's going to hurt somebody or hurt
himself so we got to institutionalize
him and i said what does that mean mom
she's well they're going to put you in a
hospital i said how long am i going to
be in the hospital she said well maybe
for the rest of your life this doesn't
look good
so so that night when everybody else was
asleep i'm sitting on the end of the bed
saying oh that doesn't sound good i want
to be in a hospital for the rest of my
life
now we lived on a farm we had a little
fence around the house and inside that
fence we kept the chickens to get the
eggs and the sheep and the pigs and
calves that we were going to slaughter
and eat later on so we're feeding them
and you know
rubbing them down and all that kind of
stuff yeah
and um
uh i said you know we're all eating the
same thing why am i the only one with
this problem i said oh now wait a minute
we're not eating the same thing remember
i'm nine years old
uh we're giving those calves
alfalfa pellets with vitamins and
minerals added in it i'm not getting
those so the next morning i threw my
cheerios out to the chicken
and um i went to the barn and i got
those
alfalfa pellets put them in my cereal
bowl put milk on it did it for three
mornings in a row by the third morning i
was cured
after five years of getting worse and
worse and worse worse 20 doctors
couldn't figure it out wow and so i said
for some reason these doctors don't know
anything about nutrition i'm only nine
years old wow so it didn't say anything
to anybody but in church
everybody is whispering and pointing to
me because now i'm singing with the
choir and all this kind of stuff instead
of being disruptive and all that kind of
stuff
finally after about a couple of months
this little lady came up to me and said
i hear he can cure my diabetes i said
ma'am i'm only nine years old i don't
even know what diabetes is
and so that night went back to
uh home and we had these little
reference books on animal diseases and
you know for the farm and so i went
through and looked up diabetes oh it's a
nutritional deficiency
and so
i went back and told her about that and
she got rid of her diabetes and so
people started coming to me for things
i'm only nine years old well to make a
long story short that's about the time
when the second world war was over and i
was a cub scout and i got into boy
scouts got 32 merit badges was a eagle
scout
and uh art of the air which is a
leadership
award
and uh graduated high school at 18 years
of age but i had the equivalent of a of
a university degree with those 32 merit
badges because you do a lot of studies
for those things and i i was taking all
the nutrition and animal husbandry
agricultural stuff
and soils fertilizer and so on
um entered agricultural school
university of missouri i wanted to get
my degree in agriculture and go back and
be a a
farmer a modern farmer and it became
very obvious
that
the world needed more than just another
farmer
and so i began to
go to lectures and that kind of stuff
and again
i'm still dealing with the scouts as a
leader scout leader at this point
and
i'm helping people get rid of arthritis
and highlight pressure and diabetes all
this kind of stuff
and about two years into agricultural
school i was wrestling for the
university of missouri and and lettering
and
my roommate which was another guy on the
wrestling team because he had all the
athletes stand together in the in the uh
dormitories
and he said i'm going to go check out
veterinary school how about coming with
me i said no i didn't come here but i
said why don't you come with me got
nothing else to do okay okay so i went
there passed all the tests got accepted
into veterinary school
and in two years time i had my degree in
agriculture as halfway through
veterinary school 1961
and it was christmas time all the
professors were off uh for the holidays
and i had to work in the pathology
department
because i didn't have any money to
finish my schooling so i worked in a
pathologist where everybody's gone i ran
into the first mass style from pollution
in america and got it published in three
scientific journals i'm 21 years old i
wanted to finish my pathology degree so
in 1964 when i graduated had my degree
in agriculture and my degree in
veterinary medicine i was halfway
through my degree in pathology because
they gave me credit for the stuff that i
was getting paid for to do because
working in the pathology lab so they
gave me credit for that kind of stuff
and so i went to iowa state university
and i was there i was supposed to finish
up in two years well you're into it
marlon perkins from the old mutual maha
wall kingdom show i don't know if you're
old enough to remember him no
okay he was he was a biologist on tv and
he he went to all these different places
on earth where animals were rare and
endangered and so on
he had
sent me to africa before i went to
university and i caught 200 white rhino
there's only 475 left i caught 200 of
them shipped them here
built three
reserves for white rhino
based on the money that uh prince
was at prince philip
actually started the world wildlife
foundation i was all involved in that
and we got a grant
for 25 million dollars from the national
institutes of health
because i wrote those papers on this
math style from pollution
and
so i came back for that
10 years i did 20 000 autopsies millions
of slides and all that kind of stuff
and basically
showed that there were no jaguar
transmitter diseases there were no
genuine transmitter birth defects my
thesis was 5 000 pages was published by
the
world's largest and most famous
publishing house wb saunders that
published medical textbooks
they published it right all right and
it's in the smithsonian institute as a
national treasure because it changed all
of science it created it created the
science of epigenetics
and so i'm very proud of that and i'm
considered one of the two fathers of
that science bruce lepton yeah yeah
bruce lipton and i are the two that are
considered the two fathers
and uh so what i've been doing all these
years
uh is working on this and i found out
the cause prevention cure of cystic
fibrosis which is supposed to be the the
the
iconic example of a genetically
transmitted disease i found the first
non-human case in a monkey from
the yerkes primate center which i was
working in 1977 for nasa as a
pathologist
and they fired me when i told them that
um
that cystic fibrosis was not genetic it
was a simple nutritional deficiencies
they fired me and that's when i went
back to school and became a naturopathic
physician yeah make a long story short
dr milan and i went to china we did 1
700 autopsies on kids under the age of
10 there
thirty-five percent had cystic fibrosis
um 100 had muscular dystrophy about 100
of them under the age of 1 years of age
would have been diagnosed with sediment
death syndrome here
so to make a long story short we got
through federal lawsuits in federal
court
uh we won uh let's see it was april 16
2013 that we were forcing these
companies that made
milk replacers like enfamil symbolic
that sort of stuff for babies to put
these nutrients in there we had to go to
court because the doctors kept coming
don't put that stuff in there while he's
talking about because they're poisonous
well the court saw my 1700 autopsies so
they couldn't
you know go against that kind of data
right
well a year and a half later after april
16 2013 when it won that lawsuit in
federal court
big headlines in the charlotte
observatory newspaper we don't know why
but sentiment destination has vanished
in the state of north carolina three
months later st louis post-dispatch in
all the newspapers in missouri we don't
know why but cinema death syndrome has
vanished in the state of missouri and
three months later every newspaper the
world came out so we don't know why but
the diagnosis of
sediment death syndrome has dropped
dramatically by 85 to 95
and then in one of the articles they
said there's a one
cinematic syndrome death
per 300 normal births
now you know why we don't know why but
now it's only one per three thousand
well that's because you're getting these
nutrients in the
baby formulas and those three diseases
the three is and that's why you haven't
heard anything about jerry lewis and the
telethon anymore
because who's gonna you know when you
find out it's a nutritional deficiency
and it's not a genetic disease you know
why would they donate money when we
already found found the prevention and
cure fart
right so that's my history and of course
we have
um 75 scientific articles published in a
half a dozen different
medical journals veterinary journals
scientific journals agricultural
journals biochemical study journals i
have 15 popular books
written bestsellers 100 cds
and
50 dvds
so we have a lot of information to give
out there to people and will freak
people out how much we know about
preventing and
eliminating these diseases including
diabetes and hybrid pressure and kidney
dialysis and arthritis and let's see
what's the pope got here diverticulitis
your story your journey
feels
like some god stuff doctor walk like
things just unfolded
so magically
and all because of animals
that's right well i'll give the good
lord all the credit
that's for sure yeah i was just
following what was put in front of me
i wanted to ask you about animal
nutrition
okay
you know when when you go look at dog
food or cat food
we can see that it's all supplemented
right there's so much
nutrients in there
yet
humans don't supplement or only a
limited amount of people supplement
is that because animals are considered a
product whether it's a pet or a zoo or
you know a cow and a farm
it's more historical than that
okay
did you ever hear of the eight plagues
that killed tens of thousands of
egyptian
military every year for eight years yeah
yeah
now the hebrews had been enslaved for
400 years
and their job i i went and looked it up
what was it the hebrew slaves did were
they washing clothes and babysitting and
cooking no they were growing wheat broth
ryan oats primarily barley and wheat
as far as for
food for the egyptian military
but they weren't allowed to eat it
now when the plagues came
none of the hebrew slaves died
that's because
i checked that out they had
fireplaces and wood stoves they're
putting the wood ashes which are
minerals into their gardens
there's just a little bit of wood ash is
not enough to fertilize the tens of
thousands of acres of barley and wheat
fields so there was none of that okay
none of those minerals in that and so
the soldiers
were getting a gluten issue
they weren't getting any supplements
and so when the play came they got hit
hard
well the hebrews
um they weren't allowed to eat the
barley and the wheat so they were
growing potatoes and carrots and
tomatoes and bell peppers and squash and
that kind of stuff
yeah
okay and they're eating seaweed yeah
and if we fast forward um
african-american
slaves
sometimes live longer than their owners
plantation owners that's correct yeah
because they were using the things that
the the white people and the plantation
owners didn't want to eat they want to
eat like the europeans
and so that's why they died at age 50
and the slaves would be 105 115 because
they're putting the wood ashes into
their little house gardens where they
were growing potatoes and carrots and
tomatoes and that kind of beans and that
kind of stuff yeah okay so that's the
you hit the nail on the head there very
good it's fast so yeah and so
uh this is one of those things where
people who are billionaires don't live
as long as poor people because they have
electricity at three o'clock in the
afternoon monday september 4th 1882 on
pearl street in new york city and the
bluff overlooking the construction of
the brooklyn bridge thomas edison and
jonathan leaves pulled the switch on the
first commercial electric generating
plants
within 10 years there was 40 new
diseases that nobody'd ever seen before
all nutritional deficient diseases but
there were it was the beginning of the
darling in science and medicine called
genetics they're blaming it all on
genetic diseases these 40 new diseases
but they're really just simply
nutritional deficiency diseases
and of course medicine went crazy was
getting pharmaceuticals to treat the
symptoms and manage the diseases like
diabetes i can take somebody who's been
a brutal diabetic for 30 years and 30
days and won't be a diabetic anymore
because it's a simple nutritional
deficit disease but doctors manage the
blood sugar and think they're doing you
a favor instead of getting rid of the
disease right and so this is the
difference between the medical system
and the veterinary system now no farmer
is going to pay
you know a veterinarian to come out
every week and every month or hall and
by truck all his animals to the
veteran's office and get tested on a
regular basis and pay for all his tests
and this and the other no way so when
these dogs came along ralston carina i
think was the first ones to put vitamins
and minerals and their pet foods
rolls from purina
and they said why don't we put all these
vitamins and minerals in there
and it'll save these people a lot of
money and they'll keep using our food
and so that's why they did that and it
worked right but dogs used to live to be
four or five years old because they're
just being fed meat and bones and things
like that once these canned foods and
dry foods came out with all these
vitamins minerals in it suddenly now
they're living to be 18 20 years old
yeah
well the same principle for humans if
you take our healthy start pack you take
our healthy brain and heart pack
stay away from the bad foods you can
maximize your absorption you'll add 25
to 50 healthy years your life
we need to be on the 90 essential
nutrients every day that's the bottom
line
that's correct and of course the 90
essential nutrients we have
our healthy start pack has the 90th
central nutrients that was our first
major product and it's the core of our
healthy brain and heart pack which has
215 nutrients in it because we added 115
nutrients to the original core program
the healthy start pack
and nobody has 215 nutrients in the
supplement you know they say oh well we
we have complete nutrition 27 nutrients
well that's not even a third of our 90
let alone 10
of the healthy brain and heart pack well
the the thing that makes it very
authentic is
it it's very much known from you and
people under you doing this
that they got to get off the gluten or
it doesn't make any sense right well you
have to help the pope because i
guarantee you when they took out half
his colon they didn't tell him look you
cannot be eating gluten anymore and he
has sciatica they said we're going to
give you cortisone prednisone deal with
your pain he didn't say you know we're
going to give you the 90 essential
nutrients plus the
glucogel and msm to rebuild your
cartilage and ligaments and tendons your
connective tissue your discs and all
kinds of stuff no they're just giving
them medication
because they're italians and they eat
gluten
and the whole thing's a mess
and so can you explain why why we have
to get off gluten
okay well gluten um has a substance in
it called
pro-inflammatory cytokines
it's produced by the the gluten protein
and protein inflammatory cytokines
destroy your villi the little finger
like restrictions in your intestine now
it doesn't happen like light on light
off
it might take 5 6 8 10 12 15 years to
really incapacitate you depending on how
much gluten you're eating if you're just
eating oatmeal for breakfast and
northern gluten it might take 15 years
but if you're eating gluten in all three
meals and you're having gluten for
snacks like cakes and cookies
and
beer and that kind of stuff made from
gluten
at 8 10 years old you might be in
serious trouble
okay
and so gluten destroys your intestinal
villi go away instead of looking like a
shag rug when you know you do autopsies
you do
surgery on your intestines you open up
the small intestine it looks like a shag
rug all those villi sticking out it
increases your absorptive surface but
when you're eating gluten those villi
shrink and shrink and shrink and
disappear because their pro-inflammatory
cytokines they disappear now when you
open up the small intestine it looks
like a smooth plastic tube you've lost
98 of your absorptive surface even if
you supplement now most people don't
supplement most people
continue to eat gluten
and because even today it was on the
news today the doctors say look you got
to stop eating
animal pro products and eat more whole
grains and of course people interpret
eating more whole grains is eating more
wheat by ryan oates right
and we have to get everybody off all the
bad foods get them on the good program
with all the 215 news i go for the 215 i
wouldn't go for the minimum i'd go for
the big big hammer in the toolbox
you'll see all these i see this all the
time
people who are really in trouble
uh like i say they have diabetes for 30
years and 30 days is gone they're on
dialysis six days a week because they
haven't peed in 10 years they're on
dialysis for a total of 25 years because
they had kidney problems for 25 years
because they're eating gluten gluten
gluten gluten gluten
and so i get them all for the gluten we
get them on the healthy brain and heart
pack the big hammer we throw in the
ultimate daily classic tablets three of
those three times a day
and in two weeks time they're urinating
so they drop the the
um
dialysis from six days a week to three
and two more weeks they're totally off
dialysis
and they were on dialysis for 25 years
because they didn't want to get a kidney
transplant right and so in just six
weeks i'd get them off of dialysis
after they've been on dialysis for 25
years even though they hadn't peed in 10
years i get them pain in two weeks
because it's an artery problem
it's not a kidney problem diabetes is a
nutritional deficiency problem not a
genetic problem
lupus is not a
autoimmune disease where your body's
attacking itself is gluten stopping you
from getting the nutrients that are
necessary to maintain your skin and your
bones and your intestines and celiac
disease and
and uh
psoriatic arthritis and all that kind of
stuff i'm four months off gluten how
long is it going to take for my stomach
to regulate
well you want to make sure everybody in
your household including the dog and the
cat and the bird and the fish and
renters and roommates and spouses
okay you cannot work in a place you
cannot work in a bakery you cannot go to
spaghetti
factory with somebody else well i don't
eat there i just have a salad when i go
to spaghetti factory with my wife well
guess what
um that waitress who delivered your
salad and delivered eight eight loaves
of bread and x number of bowls of
spaghetti
to all the tables surrounding you and
she's covered in that gluten dust you're
getting gluten even though you're not
eating it you're getting it it can
spread like it's a poison ivy that's
correct yeah is that sensitive
now how come we should not be eating
oils
okay well i'll oxidize and turn into
trans fats heterocyclines and
acrylamides which cause cancer
cause oxidative damage to your arteries
is what causes plaque in your arteries
not cholesterol now that's another big
one doctors miss they they blamed
cholesterol arteries on eggs and
and animal fats they missed that one by
a thousand miles
it's oils
and fried foods
and salad dressings and that kind of
stuff because plaque in the arteries
whether it's the brain the coronary
arteries the kidneys give you
the need for dialysis and if you want to
keep playing with the bad foods then i'm
going to go into the coffin business for
people who just won't change i think i'm
start selling coffins well i'll tell you
you know i'm a great example
i was vegan for 10 years
didn't supplement
and consumed a lot of oil and i thought
oil was good because i'd use it raw
right
i ended up with a 6.1 crp
c-reactive protein
i was deficient in essential fatty acids
vitamin a vitamin d b12
i had all these you know these symptoms
i was getting electrical shocks through
my body it was do you have any white or
gray here
i have salt and pepper now i'm 42 so
yeah see well that's not aging that's
the deficiency of a particular nutrient
you have any varicose well don't say
that
because people run out and buy a copper
thinking they're going to save
themselves and then they die because
they didn't take the other 89. right
right i used to tell people they'd say
well what nutrient is that oh i would
tell them and then we go to walgreens
and they buy that nutrient and then
three months later whatever happened to
your husband frankie oh he did what you
said he took that nutrient and he died
two months later
so i stopped telling people what it was
because
they only want to take one they don't
want to take all 90.
right
okay and so i don't want to participate
in suicide you might as well here's a
gun a bullet shoot yourself in the head
if all you're gonna do is take one right
you gotta take them all yeah and i do
have varicose veins now i'm on the 90th
century i'm off to gluten i'm off the
oils
well
how long have you been on the program
since april first
okay so yeah you should start seeing
a reduced amount of the gray hair you
should see the varicose veins getting
smaller and fewer
and you want to see if you're getting
cross-contaminated in the laundry the
food preparation surfaces your workplace
you really really want to look around
and see if you're getting contaminated
because if you're still getting
cross-contaminated with gluten that
would say why you haven't really seen
more in 30 60 90 days yeah well my crp
has come down
okay good it's a 2.5 now and you know
i'm i'm i'm getting back you know i'm
i'm building back you know
but
but here's the question there's a lot of
people listening right now that might be
vegan
they need these 90 essential and what
would where would they get their
essential fatty okay
that's why we have efas and the fa
pluses efas are from seeds and efa
pluses are from fish livers
okay but here's what i tell them
if you want to be a vegetarian or vegan
i want you to be an ovo pisco vegetarian
there's no red meat and fish as the
piscos
have you ever incubated a chick
for 21 days an incubator or you know an
egg
underneath the hen for 21 days
no but i have a friend who did
okay now what happens here is the chick
after 21 days either in the incubator or
under the hen goes from that white spot
to a perfect chick heart beating pumping
blood all over the place has kidneys at
work liver that works lungs it works
gastrointestinal tract that works eyes
that work brain that works muscles and
bones and joints that work all from that
one little spot because of all the
nutrition in that egg don't tell me
there's no nutrition in an egg if you're
going to be an ovo lacto pisco
vegetarian or ovolactopisco vegan you
will survive and flourish and do well
and you have beautiful babies
but if you want to avoid all that stuff
and just eat vegetables and grains
you're going to die early you'll be
miserable you'll have the worst time of
your life in your last years of your
life
because
you don't get the nutrients you need
because you're eating gluten and there's
no nutrition in food anymore because
farmers get paid by tons and bushels
farmers don't get paid by how much
nutrition is in the food
so they're willing to accept npk
fertilizers because it gives them the
maximum yields in terms of tons and
bushels or acres and they get paid by
tons and bushels for acres so that's the
direction they go but they know to give
the vitamins metals to their animals
where i got introduced to it right so
they don't have to have the veterinarian
come out there and treat all these
diseases
so they went through that
[Laughter]
so
vegans and vegetarians have a choice
they can have a short
life or they can have a long life
if they follow what i say i'll add 25 to
50 healthier life
so we can be plant-based just add in
some eggs some fish 90 essential
nutrients
and some cheese and some cheese and
dairy yeah
so dr wallach what about birth defects
how many ob gyns help people who are in
the childbearing years both men and
women be sure you're taking the 90th
century nutrients well i'm on birth
control and don't plan on having babies
take the 90 essential nutrients because
if you get pregnant
you're going to be in trouble
yeah okay so
you start supplementing with the 90s
center nutrients now and we can
eliminate all
earth defects
and it's called what epigenetics
epigenetics
okay if you take all your 90 essential
nutrients even if you're taking birth
control and not dating
remember
um
20 years is a long time
and who knows when along the line you're
gonna you know have a couple of drinks
and say okay tonight's tonight we're
gonna go for it right and so you get
pregnant and you haven't been taking
your prenatal vitamins because you
weren't planning on getting pregnant and
so the baby's born with cleft palates
spina bifida
or you know all kinds of stuff heart
defects we can avoid all this
all that's totally avoidable none of
it's genetic none of it's autoimmune
it's all nutritional deficiencies in the
embryo even things like sickle cell
anemia and blacks it's not a genetic
thing in blacks
it's a deficiency of the bone marrow
cells that are farming in the early
embryo when these cells that make the
hemoglobin are farming makes the effect
of hemoglobin and white folks sickle
cell anemia is called thalassemia
because they couldn't call it sickle
cell anemia it was supposed to be a
genetic disease black folks so they gave
it a different name in white guys is
called thalassemia and white guys but as
sickle cell anemia in black guys was a
birth defect caused by
nutritional deficiencies early in
embryonic life when the hemoglobin
farming cells were forming in the bone
marrow or those early embryos
i want to run through a bunch of
diseases and you you give me the skinny
on them we already talked about diabetes
how about asthma
asthma is due to a nutritional
deficiency i'm not going to tell you
which one but if you get rid of all the
gluten
which interferes specifically with those
nutrient absorption
and you take the
healthy brain and heart pack take the
healthy rain hard pack one per hundred
pounds of body weight
and if you have a little kid let's say
the kid is
three years old and not going to take
two healthy branded heart packs
they're three years old we have kids
toddy
and the efas
and the cal toddy
and put that in their
milk or their drinks or whatever
and you'll be giving them all the
nutrients they're necessary to get rid
of their asm in weeks
asthma goes away very quickly it's very
simple nutritional deficient disease but
you got to get rid of gluten so you can
absorb the nutrition
and you have to supplement with these
nutrients
forever i've been
gluten free for 74 years i've been
taking the 90 cents of nutrients
74 years but i've been taking also the
healthy brain heart pack the 215
nutrients for the last 15 years
how about
arthritis
arthritis very simple nutritional
deficiencies i came up with the healthy
bone and joint pack for theo ratliff one
of our great basketball players and made
our rebounds for string for him
and he he had lost his position with the
atlanta hawks
24 years old a bowling ball arthritis in
both his knees partly he's popped off
his hips fractured his right wrist and a
shooting arm
lost a big contract two months later he
went back he passed all the tests
and he got 35 million dollar contract he
played for
11 more years made over 135 million
dollars using my products to rebuild it
and so
um
when you look at evander holyfield great
heavyweight boxer he lost his
heavyweight championship to michael
moore uh he couldn't answer the bell for
the 12th final round of his heavyweight
championship defense
because he had a near fatal heart attack
so he came up with a healthy brain and
heart pack then for him
and we already had the rebound at that
time
and he took it two three times a day for
a year and a half and he went back and
he beat iron mike tyson
for the heavyweight championship now who
comes back from a near-death heart
attack
and beats iron mike tyson right
okay in a heavyweight championship fight
somebody who's been taking my health
abandoned heart pack stay away from
gluten
yeah
how about
prostate inflammation
okay prostate inflammation could be two
things number one it could be a prostate
problem number two would be a back
problem a lot of times doctors they're
they're famous for misdiagnosing we've
already talked about a dozen things that
they've misdiagnosed
um your
sciatic nerves some of them control your
bladder some will control your prostate
and your erections and all that kind of
stuff
and when doctors say oh you have a
prostate problem because you're either
peeing in your pants all the time or you
can't urinate without a catheter
you have a prostate problem
and they will get you on some um
prostate medications
and some
hormones and it may or may not help but
you have to keep catheterizing yourself
that's because it's a back problem
squeezing the
sciatic nerves controlling your bladder
and so you get off all the bad foods you
take the healthy brain and heart pack
and msm rebuild your disc rebuild
vertebrae take the pressure off those
sciatic nerves your bladder starts
working again keep your prostate you
know give me 90 days when your doctor
wants to remove your prostate give me 90
days before you
agree to that surgery because the odds
are 95 chance is really just
a low back problem squeezing the sciatic
nerves to control the bladder
how about the neurologicals like ms and
parkinson's
let's say 75 percent of the brain weight
is cholesterol
there's parker disease there's als
let's see here alzheimer's disease
there's all kinds of stuff going on in
the brain right parkinson's disease and
almost all of them are due to
nutritional deficiencies
but
what happens here is
some part for just chance some parts of
the brain are more seriously affected so
they get different sets of symptoms so
the different guys give it named after
themselves and give it different names
but they all take the same thing three
eggs twice a day soft yolks take the
90th cents of nutrients or better yet
the 215 nutrients to healthy brain and
heart pack take the de-stress capsules
through those twice a day
take the ultimate niacin plus one of
those twice a day take the ultimate
niacin to me the ultimate
daily classic tablets in case it's a
vascular dementia um take three of those
with each meal that's three bottles a
month the ultimate daily
classic tablets
and for circulation into the brain
and then
don't forget the eggs and don't forget
the synaptive which gives you the raw
material specifically for your brain
cells to make the biological systems so
they can talk to each other and work in
synchrony and so on
don't forget hgh our human growth
hormone and the the master gland the
pituitary gland in the brain but also it
works with the rest of the brain tune
the hypothalamus which again controls
who you're going to chase for sex
and so all of these things i've been
taking these nutrients for 74 years
i've been gluten-free for 74 years
and so that's why we came up with our
own versions of all these nutrients
because i was tired of buying them from
the pharmacies and this set and the
other and it was obvious that doctors
weren't going to go that direction
so we began to form our own company and
form our own versions of these
various nutrients
well the
the moral of the story seems to be
we need cholesterol for blame for brain
health and neurological
function
well not only that but also 95 of the
weight of testosterone's
cholesterol guess who started ed
erectile dysfunction
medical doctors when they came up with
statin drugs lower cholesterol because
they incorrectly thought there was
cholesterol blocking the arteries no it
was oxidized oils blocking the arteries
so if someone's not a statin drug
they may end up with neurological issues
they're going to wind up with
neurological issues
guys will wind up with erectile
dysfunction
and ladies
will wind up with menopause at age 25
because women tend to follow the
doctor's instructions i mean to the
letter you got to get off
no eggs no cholesterol we're going to
give you because your cholesterol is 20
points too high
that's nothing okay 20 points too high
so we're going to go
uh with the
um satin drugs here you're going to be
on this for the rest of your life yes
sir yes doctor
i don't want to have a heart attack and
so they get on all this stuff
and then they wind up with alzheimer's
disease in three years
and cholesterol is really just a marker
for something else sometimes liver
well yeah liver um
uh liver utilizes cholesterol any any
hormone in the body adrenal glands use
cholesterol yeah and so cholesterol is a
very very useful
biological raw material we need it don't
let a doctor talk you into getting on
statin drugs and giving up cholesterol
in your diet yeah this is also another
thing that a lot of vegans run into
they're deficient in cholesterol
and essential fatty acids it's funny
because the joke is always where do you
get your protein
it kind of should be where do you get
your essential fatty acids where do you
get your cholesterol that's correct
very good
all right next adhd or add
uh aed adhd
autism those kinds of things again
um
want to eat and the eggs
take this program the healthy brain and
heart pack
that's essentially what i had they
didn't have a name for it when i was you
know a nine-year-old kid but i was a
very violent
uh very violent um
kid with add adhd
so we don't have that anymore in any of
our people who are with longevity
because they take all the nutrients
and so you see
um you haven't heard of
cystic fibrosis anymore you haven't
heard of muscular dystrophy anymore you
haven't and they were so crazy about the
monster history they fired jerry lewis
they fired him and the telethon died
without jerry lewis
muscular dystrophy association since
because i came out with the cause
preventing cure of muscular history now
you'd think they'd be overjoyed
and they could have really been on the
front end of all this
and been a bigger part of this whole
thing
and no instead the medical doctor said
this guy's crazy no no no he's infected
jerry lewis we got to get rid of him
because it's a genetic disease
and they went away
well in animals it was called white
muscle disease right that is correct
very good
so different name same disease that's
correct but they're all vertebrates
same tissues same organ sets
and same diseases to the same
nutritional deficiencies
what a theory do they fix it in the
animals
oh yeah but not in the humans that's
correct
that's because there's no insurance for
the animals no health insurance so the
farmer had to pay out of his own pocket
so the agricultural schools figured it
out
this is caused by deficiency of don't
say
it right
okay and so it's all in you know you get
your 90 essential nutrients and
better yet if you have three four five
six eight ten different diseases you
have all these pre-existing conditions
when
the medical establishment uses the word
genetics like oh well that your heart
disease must be genetic what they really
mean to say is
your parents pass down nutritional
deficiencies all they're saying is those
doctors are saying i have no earthly
idea what causes this but i'm not going
to take the blame for not knowing so i'm
going to blame it on your family's genes
and that way
you have to look back to your family
well you know i'm the first one of my
family that's ever had this
i've got five generations that are still
alive and none of them ever had any of
this they're the oldest ones 120 none of
this stuff
but the doctors say oh it's genetic
okay that's because he doesn't want to
admit just like when sentiment death
syndrome he didn't want to admit that he
didn't know why those babies were dying
so he said the mother must have laid on
him
that's what sentiment is in rome i made
him change the name to crib death
because 98 of the babies that died of
sudden death syndrome were in the cribs
when they died not in bed with their
mothers
so i made him change the name to crib
death
and then um the two percent were in bed
with her mothers they weren't laid on by
their mothers they died of hypertrophy
cardiomyopathy heart disease the same
thing that kills five hundred to a
thousand young athletes in america every
year and that's why our rebounds for
shrink i have four times the minimum
daily requirement of that one nutrient
in our spore strength so that any
athlete who takes our sports drink is
not going to die
a heart attack
well that's a good segue because
i wanted to ask you that why do so many
athletes not make it to their 90s and
100s
well because they have a false belief
they have a false belief that exercise
is good for you
and so
basically
the average lifespan when you take all
professional and olympics forwards
combined gary's lifespan of these
professional olympic athletes is 62
except for basketball players which is
51.
the average lifespan
of a drunk doing everything wrong is 75
in the united states
why is that well the athletes are
exercising they're eating all these
whole grains
and
the only supplements they take is red
bull for energy you know sugar and
caffeine
kind of thing and there's and they're
saying yeah because they're sweating and
so they but they want the energy
and they're still missing all the
nutrients but they think they're eating
well because they're getting all these
grains
that's the problem the grains are the
problem we look at the asians ate grain
but they don't eat wheat broth around
oats they ate rice and sweet potatoes
well and sweet potatoes
yeah yeah and they they corn eat maize
and they'll eat millet and buckwheat
those kinds of things but they don't eat
wheat butter in oats
except for
people uh who
were occupied by the british you know
like india
uh the northern nine states in india
were occupied for a hundred years by
by the um english
they were drafting all their young
people to be in the english army that's
why you saw so many movies where you
were looking at the english army and it
had so many people from india with the
turbines in the english army
and for a hundred years the english were
northern
india
so why does
the
top nine states in india the northern
nine states in india have 95 of the
deaths from covet and 87 of the
infections the southern 20 states and
seven territories have five percent of
the deaths and only 13 of the infections
same people very homogeneous people
that's because
the ones in the north
for a hundred years the british were
there growing wheat broth around oats
when the british left they were still
growing wheat butter and oats they're
still growing wheat broth around oats
there they have a gluten issue and
they're not supplementing for the ones
in the south they live in the swamps in
the rain forest and they're growing
rice
and peas and beans and squash and
seaweed which has all these minerals in
the seaweed because they live near the
coast in the south
and it's a dietary thing
it's no doubt a dietary thing if you
supplement and stay away from gluten and
take your 90
even if you don't vaccinate you're going
to come out good these are people who
get it and
and don't die
but the people who
get vaccinated
they get the double vaccination all that
kind of stuff
and they die two months after the second
vaccination
why that happened because they weren't
supplementing they were eating gluten
they couldn't absorb nutrients their
bone marrow is dead their immune system
is dead so they cannot respond to the
vaccines because the vaccines do not
kill viruses bacteria fungus they just
alert your body to bad dna and rna so
when the bug comes you know that there's
the bad guy yeah speaking of covid i
mean india got nailed and they're high
gluten
yeah that's right so that's the northern
one they have 95 of the deaths i want to
ask you about calcium
you have in the osteo formula
there's a there's a big dose of calcium
in there
100 milligrams yeah
so
you know a lot of calcium supplements
are a lot lower than that yeah some have
200 300. yeah
some doctors would say that you can't
have too much so how come you you go for
the high dose
i think it's going to change but right
now there's still an enormous number of
people who are not going to give up
gluten they're not going to go up we
brought around oats
and so you have to give them something
that's going to compensate for that
inefficiency of absorption okay
so let's say they're only absorbing 10
well 10
of
1000 milligrams is a hundred
okay
so if somebody's off gluten for three
four or five months and they've been
taking the 90 essential nutrients
can at that point can they back off from
the osteo formula they don't need the
big dose of calcium anymore
well we need a hair analysis to find out
are they absorbing
okay we need to find those kinds of
things out and so that's why we have the
book uh rare urism and cures go to
chapter 10 11 tells you how to
collect the hair
uh how to box it up where to ship it to
don't forget to put the check in because
the lab's not going to run the test off
the check
and usually in two to four weeks you'll
have the analysis back if all the bars
and the hair analysis are down below the
bottom line that means you're not
absorbing that's easy
and then there's two charts one for the
essential nutrients and the other is for
toxic metals
okay like mercury
lead
uranium those kind of things and so um i
do that once a year i just have one of
my i have a hair analysis once a year
just to know what's going on
and my
cost is it's a hundred bucks i think but
it's tax deductible because in my
business plan it says that my young
jimmy business will pay for my health
care my health insurance and any lab
test i need and any special diet i need
so it's all tax deductible if we're a
distributor in youngevity can we we
could write off our tests
of course what you want to do is get
that book that's great it's called yeah
you get the book walsh wallace street
for kids aka wall street for kids
wallace street for kids aka wall street
for kids it tells you how to make a
business plan
so that let's say you're using 25 of
your home
for your youngevity business
and let's say just for easy calculation
your mortgage is a thousand bucks
a month or your rent or whatever it is a
thousand bucks a month and you're using
25 so it's 250 bucks you get to deduct
every month off your taxes now it gets
better than this
let's say you also have utilities air
conditioning heat light you get to
deduct 25
off your light bill your utility bill
you have to deduct 25 over your
homeowner's insurance and if your car if
you're using your car to go give
lectures or to go pick up your products
and delivery and and
so forth
um guess what or go to class
you get to deduct 25 of your car payment
unless you make your business the owner
of the car then the entire car payment
and insurance and all that kind of stuff
is totally tax deductible
how come you decided to make youngevity
an mlm once somebody
gets that health freedom
they want to scream it from the top of
the mountain right they want to tell
everyone
yeah well really i started out
with an mlm because when i became a
naturopathic physician
i really didn't look into it very hard
and i didn't realize that naturopathic
doctors back in those days in 1982 we're
seeing five patients a day no health
insurance paid for any naturopathic care
right or lab test or anything like that
it was just
you had to eat it right because and so
you'd see five to ten people a day
whereas medical doctors are seeing 45 to
60 people a day because they're getting
all those lab tests and the visits and
everything paid for by
and the pharmaceuticals and
prescriptions all paid for by health
insurance
so that's where everybody's going
because of health insurance right well
um so i started giving lectures and i
was handing out my card with samples of
some of my products and i say i won't
charge you the first time you come see
me i'll give you the office visit for
free and if you need lab tests um you
know you have to pay for the lab test
but the office call for free and so i
got up to about 18 to 25 people a day
it's getting kind of exciting and i'm
still going all over oregon and
washington state and northern
california
and western
idaho and utah and
north and south dakota to lecturing and
trying to drive more patients into my
clinic
and
one day i'm at a truck stop
and the truckers are
sitting next to me
and they're complaining that they're
going to have to quit trucking because
the phone bills are so expensive
that they
they couldn't earn enough money to pay
for their phone bill to earn the money
it was kind of this terrible circle here
they were
losing money by taking long-distance
jobs you know going to the coast with
something and coming back for something
from the coast because of all the phone
bills they had to have
and i said i think i can help you guys
um i belong to this company
that
sells
um
phone service
mci is called i don't know you're
probably not old enough to remember mci
i remember
okay mci
and so i said i can sign you up in this
and i'll eliminate 80 of your phone bill
if you sign up other truckers
even if you never see them again and
they're using the phone you're going to
get a percentage of their phone bill
they're going back and forth across the
place and running up all those phone
bills you're going to get a percentage
of their phone bills in a check every
month
from my company
and say we're in
and so don't forget you can sign up all
these other guys
and within three months i was making 300
000 a month just from the mci card
and so i said this is what i have to do
i have to do this for my business
because just word of mouth isn't quite
good enough i have to become a network
marketing company
and we call it a home-based business
because people are many people are
offended by network marketing because
they've run into some bad characters and
so on i can appreciate that yeah so we
can we call it a home
home business
get all the tax breaks you don't have to
rent or buy a store
or any kind of manufacturing facility or
anything like that or an outlet or
anything of that nature
we
you can run this out of your home i mean
my home 25 of my home here in southern
california
is my office
my warehouse
my consulting room
and um of course so 25 of my mortgage
and 25 of my utilities and 25 of my
homeowners insurance and all of my
car payments and stuff like that are all
tax deductible because it's all part of
my business plan yeah it makes sense and
uh you know i'm i'm on the team and i'm
i'm building something here in hartford
connecticut and
you know the these products are great
and people are getting better i mean the
proof is in the pudding right
absolutely and of course they tell
people and say you know you tell anybody
else and they want to join you need to
join up so when they join they'll be
you're one of your people and so every
time they buy something you'll get a
little check from us
and um
that way you know you can
we want you to support the boy scouts
the girl scouts they need to be doing
this boy scouts the girl scouts
they saved america after the second
world war is over they can save america
now
and
they'll by dealing with all these people
with these problems they'll be able to
earn more merit badges and service pins
and their their rank will go up which
will be very nice for getting jobs and
so forth but also we'll send them a
check every month based on the volume
they create from their business with
youngevity and also
um
they will
in addition to getting a check from us
they'll get a car bonus you tell a 10
year old
cub scout or boy scout or girl scout or
brownie that they can get a car bonus at
10 years of age and a big check every
month and they put in the bank account
so that when they graduate high school
at 18 years of age they got 50 000 100
000 in their college fund
that's exciting for them and they'll go
out and they'll help people with their
health issues
and they'll get their merit badges done
because they have all these merit badges
that deal with the health issues and
exercise and cooking and all that kind
of stuff so they'll get those merit
badges and and
uh the the pins
but also they'll get an income stream
and they'll
they'll get their own supplements so
they'll be healthy as well
yeah
win-win everyone wins everyone wins
speaking of blood tests you mentioned
blood tests just a few minutes ago
is it even worth going to a doctor and
getting a blood test
well most of the things you can do
yourself you get a hair analysis to see
if you're absorbing
right you can see if you have toxic
metals
uh you can also
get these test strips for about 50 each
to see if you have diabetes you can
stick your finger or you can uh get one
for urine you can test your kidneys
you can do your own blood pressure
and you can go you don't even need a
blood pressure kit because you go to a
pharmacy they let you sit in their chair
and they do all that furry for nothing
okay you don't need to go to a doctor to
see if you're obese you get on the scale
if you're 25 pounds over your ideal
weight for your body for your height
guess what you're obese all this is in
the book
i have a set it used to be called the
trilogy books now it's called the quartz
head of books let's play doctor let's be
herbal doctor passport chromotherapy and
it's all in your head goes into 600
different diseases that you can deal
with yourself
prevent reverse
so we really don't need the medical
establishment except for emergency
infection
trauma and trauma yeah
insulin if we need it to hold us over
when you look at you go back to um
malaria
all right
the the first drugs for malaria came
from peru from the shinshona tree bark
and they took that all over the world
uh kept malaria under control for
hundreds of years
it wasn't until until 1939 when this guy
invented ddt and started killing
mosquitoes malaria disappeared
they were just managing malaria
with his
herb
okay
but then once they got the
um ddt to kill the mosquitoes
wasn't transmitted anymore
right duh
and so
these are the sort of things you have to
look at you have to look at
all the aspects of a disease and not
just the symptoms whereas medical system
all they look at is the symptoms because
they want the patient to be happy within
24 to 48 hours so doc you're what 83 82
82 82 yeah
so what's your routine what's your diet
look like what's your supplement routine
well my diet is every morning for
breakfast i'll have three poached eggs
with soft yolks
two or three slices of five the size of
a slice of bread but not that thick
about a millimeter thick of smoked
uh sockeye red salmon from
wild salmon from alaska
or
a couple of lamb chops or gluten-free
pizza
and then i also have wild rice three big
scoops of wild rice which i use are pink
himalayan salt on with butter and i have
two of these four ounce yogurts
new some
yogurts i like the lemon
and i
have two of those they're gluten free
and sugar-free
and then i have all my supplements of
course they have the healthy brain and
heart pack i have about um
25 sometimes i'll show you the table
behind me i have um
40 different bottles on there
and i take three to five of those
tablets and capsules out of each one of
those twice a day
i go through a lot of stuff
because i can't afford to get sick
because i'm a travel and all this kind
of stuff
and so for lunch i have these babybel
cheeses
along
with
our rebound sports drink
sometimes i'll have a piece of the
gluten-free pizza
but then for dinnertime i'll have lamb
chops from
australia i'll have
t-bone steaks i'll have the gluten-free
pizzas i'll have
sweet potatoes with butter and
pink himalayan salt with a ground black
pepper in it
and so
i will also have
vegetables i will have things like
carrots and
tomatoes and celery and squash and
things like that for salads
and
i do have a glass of wine with dinner i
do have my ice cream
and i think uh that covers the territory
you're taking the z radical
oh yeah
and i take z radical and i also take the
fucoid z which is the capsule form of
the same recipe i take a z radical i
take a cal toddy
i take
the btt 2.0 i take the sticks of the
rebound
you're loaded
on nutrition
yeah i
of course i have to i pay for things the
company doesn't give me people say well
yeah you're getting it free because you
own the company
i pay for all my supplements
i do exactly as all our distributors do
i pay for my own supplements i don't get
a single product for free even when
we're looking at product samples if this
if the company that we're looking at
gives us free samples i'll get some of
those
once it becomes our product though i
have to pay for everything and 20
i plan on living to be at least
um a super centenarian 110 to 150
somewhere between 110 150
would be reasonable
but who knows
uh doing this for as long as i've been
doing it i don't step out in front of a
car that kind of stuff or get killed in
an airplane crash yeah um kind of thing
um
i could live to be the age of the the
people from hunter their average
lifespan is 120.
and their oldest super centenarians
lived in their 160s 160s
and
uh right now in america we've had over
the past
let's see here 100 years we've had 70
000 centenarians 70 000 100 olds over
the last hundred years
we've had um 32 super centenarians
which are 110 years old and older but
that's about it we don't have anybody
living being 150 160 that kind of stuff
our average lifespan now because the
code is 75 we're leaving 80 years on the
table and so why not be like these
hunzas
who the longest lived ones and only they
don't live leave any years on the table
they're they're
living longer than the human life
expectancy in in the world which 155
and they live to be 160
and so they're the only ones
now you look at you look at um
russia
they live to be 72 you subtract that
from 155 they leave 83 years on the
table france
is um let's see here 87 so they're
leaving 73 years on the table
um
hunza
lives to be 82 they're leaving 73 years
on the table
excuse me new zealand new zealand leaves
82 years on the table
um that's their exercise so they're
leaving 73 years on the table
um
the philippines lived to be 69.6
they leave 80 85.4 years on the table
and um the medical doctors in the
emergency rooms their average lifespan
is 57 they leave 98 years on the table
doctors know nothing about longevity
they know nothing about longevity now if
you get run over by a truck and you're
bleeding internally you got to go to an
emergency room
but if you want to live a long healthful
life
you get the
quartet of books let's play doctoralist
for herbal doctor passport chromotherapy
it's all on your head get the hair
analysis get on the healthy brain and
heart pack and all the
secret sauces necessary to deal with all
the different diseases
that you might have your pre-existing
conditions get rid of those
and you'll add
you know 25 to 50 healthy years your
life
and so
but you got to be proactive here you
can't have one cheat day a month you
cannot have one cheat day month
you must be really really i mean fired
up and this is the way it is
well my priority is to give everybody in
the world 25 to 50 more healthful years
give them the information give them
availability the products and the
know-how through books and cds and dvds
um
www.drjwalik.com www.drjwok.com
and
add those years to your life enjoy your
kids your grandkids your grandkids your
great-grandkids your
great-great-grandkids
and why not i'm inspired to go make some
babies right now
make sure you're taking the good stuff
got to be on the 90 essential first
right that's right yeah for at least at
least six months and of course the
ladies got to be on for at least six
months also off the gluten at least six
months on the 90. you must do this
forever because you got to be
show the kid that you're doing this so
as they're growing up they're going to
be doing it
and so you're going to pass on this
longevity you're going to pass on this
good health to your offspring and your
um
kids that come from you okay
we were designed
to have proper nutrition right that's
correct
it's called the garden of eden
all right how about pineapple i got
pineapple on my shirt here
well it's fine how many nutrients are in
that pineapple you don't know
i have no idea
okay so you take your 90 centimetres and
eat your pineapple
it works for me
dr wallach this has been a pleasure
thank you for your time
well thank you for having me let's do it
again
thanks for listening to inner peace
with dr reese
if this episode opened your heart
feel free to share on social media
and tell your loved ones
also be sure to subscribe
so you never miss an episode
until next time
may peace be with you